hey guys merry here with a gamespot news
update it looks like divinity original
sin is getting a sequel tentatively
titled divinity still Sinan just kidding
it sounds like they're calling it
divinity original sin to which is ok
developer Larian is turning to
kickstarter once again for funding
they've launched a website that
announced the Kickstarter will be
launching on august 26 the official
website for the game allows fans to
submit and vote for the stretch goals
with some of the top contenders right
now being adult mode for extra gore and
nudity more playable races and 4 player
co-op vote for still Sinan there's
currently no details on the game but
Larian is calling it its most ambitious
RPG ever with the launch of the
Kickstarter in two weeks we should know
a lot more PAX Prime running at the end
of August should also bring more news
because Larian said they will have a
playable prototype of the game that will
showcase some of the games unique
features the original divinity original
sin garnered 944 thousand dollars during
its kickstarter and went on to win games
caught pc game of the year award not too
shabby hopefully the prototype at taxes
have the new skill trees I'm really
excited to check that out the latest on
the sequel to divinity original sin be
sure to stay tuned to gamespot com
you